It was Mr. Freeze.
Right.
But they've got to Ben AFLAC and they were like,
Nah,
player when I,
whoa.
Isn't that funny?
Like that's real,
like the amount of people that will see you as Batman.
It's whether or not they really believe it.
Like Christian Bale,
I believe that God can be Batman.
But Michael Keaton for a longest time was Batman.
Yes.
But see,
he started it off.
See that the difference between Michael Keaton is there was no one before him
other than Bruce Wayne.
And he was the first dark real Batman.
I forgot about val Kilmer.
God dammit.
Val Kilmer was fucking Batman.
What a talented human being.
Val Kilmer.
He's a beast.
Dude.
Him as a doc holiday.
Oh,
in that,
um,
what's his,
what's the name of that movie?
Tombstone.
God Damn.
This is one of the best.
That's one of the best.
He was spooky ever.
He was believable.
That was a,
that was a straight up murder.
I still the most quoted,
but see,
nobody will think back on Ben Affleck's career and be like,
he was Batman.
It's not just that he's done some good move.
Yeah,
but he's also,
he always says there's nothing around his career that he,
he must feel like,
oh man,
if if this goes bad,
it's going to ruin me.
He's done so many great things.
He's a very good actor.
Don't get me wrong,
but
what is it about him as he too handsome?
No,
because val Kilmer is gorgeous.
They're all,
but all those folks were very handsome.
Is it Gigli?
Is it him and Jennifer Lopez?
It's time for us.
It's a tough time.
She just say Giglio cheaply.
I think it was Gili.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Look,
not everybody should get that kind of pussy.
It's just,
it shouldn't be on your diet.
It's too rich for you.
Some people get diabetes,
right?
They need to lay off the sugar.
Everybody's got different tolerance cake every morning.
Jennifer loaf has,
obviously,
besides being beautiful and having a body like some sort of a test tube person,
some lab created super freak.
Obviously she knows how to throw that thing.
She knows how to throw that thing.
I mean,
it'd be hard to,
it'd be hard to argue with that fact.
Yeah,
that's some Goddamn Nolan Ryan Pussy Shit.
Look at,
yeah.
Yeah.
I together.
I am not unaware of what you're talking about.
I love the fact that those things go so hard to go so hard and then they fizzle
out.
They just,
you know what it's like.
It's like having a,
like a pinto with a fucking corvette.
Zr One engine stuff.
Don't stomp on the gas on the highway and there's no structure to it,
but listen,
design,
those wheels are not designed for that relationship.
Is that why I'm no,
you live in Hollywood.
You're telling me.
Is that why these Hollywood relationships always like become huge and then go
away?
Sometimes they do.
Sometimes they work.
I live in Montana animal.
Here's my thing.
This Alex Rodriguez guy that she's with super athlete smashes it.
Obviously it seems to be working.
They've been together for a long time.
How long have they been together though?
Months
play with the other six weeks.
She,
when she was with that little dog singer,
she got mad.
He was at the UFC that one time,
remember?
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
And then she left.
Which one was that?
That was the dancer.
Can I,
can we take a quick,
like a kind of a PSA,
public service announcement.
Can we take a hard left of Jennifer Lopez and get ourselves every Kanye West
real quick?
Yeah,
we can,
but look at that Alex Rodriguez.
Okay.
Take a look at that man.
Super Athlete.
Probably got a Dick like a Goddamn baseball bat.
Right?
Anybody that has that many buttons.
Look at,
there's top buttons coming down size of his fist,
this size that guys,
Paul,
he said two plus $200 million contract.
Yes.
So He's,
he's just gotten $400 million in a giant hot super athlete.
Of course it's going to work.
It's going to smash.
You seem to keep it together.
Let's talk about hunting.
He knows that guy knows how to keep it together.
Right?
That guy knows,
he knows how to know when the ball's coming his way.
He smashes that fucking thing.
Right?
I think Jennifer Lopez is not tolerating any losers in her life at this point.
That's all that's left.
She's had a few,
but that's awesome.
Look at that guy.
There you go.
Super Athlete.
Big giant Hanson.
I'm a big sports fan.
I came up when he was just,
he was,
it was a god,
a baseball God.
They seem to get along together.
Seed.
That makes sense to me.
Just like it made sense with Val Kilmer was Batman.
They made sense to me,
but when Ben Affleck was Ben Affleck,
I don't know how his relationship was with her.
I don't know.
Maybe it was great.
It seemed like it was a tumultuous,
but I'm not.
I'm just observing.
I'm like,
do I know?
Nobody knows,
but there's like some people will you need to like have an online vote.
Should this person be Batman?
The people will tell you they would not have voted.
I do not believe they would have voted for Ben Affleck.
I do not believe.
Here's the problem.
Like the rock too big for that man.
Here's why.
Because everybody would be like,
oh,
it's you.
The Rock you wearing a fucking bat suit?
Is that the [inaudible] 69 they would,
they could do that in the movie.
They can make it funny.
It'd be like,
yeah,
are you in the movie?
They could make it funny,
but yeah,
right.
Is this the rock or the rock?
He could never be superman takes his fucking glasses.
I feel like you're still a giant dude.
The last time I shit doesn't work,
but that's how it works.